the teachers union in New York City got
together with the n-double-a-cp
and sued to essentially kick charter
schools out of buildings I'm Bob Bowden
I started choice Media TV which is an
education or forum homepage we hope to
be covering news and opinion columns
about education reform we really thought
that this was kind of a vertical subject
matter the reform in particular aspect
of education that needed a website that
covered it every day as the education
reform movement explodes charter schools
only grow in number every year
homeschooling is a double-digit growth
rates also ten year reforms and lastin
first-out and seniority pay provisions
are changing merit pay that kind of
thing teacher evaluations are changing
all around the country we've covered
stories from the New Orleans charter
school turnaround to the Atlanta
cheating scandal to vouchers being a
voucher law being overturned by a court
in Colorado one story that we covered
came from a release from the Seattle
Public Schools and it was called the
achievement gap that isn't racial what
the Seattle Public Schools found is that
the black kids that came from Africa
that were born in Africa and are now in
Seattle public schools of which they're
almost a thousand not a tiny number are
academically outperforming the black
kids who were born in America in those
schools and so for those who talk about
the racial achievement gap in America
it's an important subject and it's it's
been debated for quite a long time
this kind of data was shocking to see in
that scenario it's it's not about race
it's about culture and what it
essentially showed is that you know
culture matters
one other story covered was this suit
where the teachers union in New York
City got together with the n-double-a-cp
and sued to essentially kick charter
schools out of buildings where they were
co-located with regular district schools
this caused rallies on both sides in New
York City many said the n-double-a-cp
is suing the very schools that are
helping black kids in New York the most
that almost a hundred percent minority
kids in these charter schools why is the
n-double a-c-p that's supposed to be
serving the interests of black kids
opposing these schools who were almost
doing nothing but helping black kids and
eventually the the suit was won by the
charter schools and within a week a new
suit was launched saying that all right
word instead of kicking them out we want
to make them pay a hundred million
dollars in rent for co-locating these
would be would have been empty floors in
district schools in New York City but
the teachers union wants to basically
make sure that they pay a hundred
million dollars which is crippled many
of these struggling charter schools
after the suit was announced it then hit
the media that cash had been transferred
from the teachers union to the
n-double-a-cp and to the groups who made
the second suit about rent being paid by
the charter schools in other words while
I can't prove a quid pro quo these
groups like the n-double-a-cp that were
suing charter schools are being paid by
the unions at the same time it's
infuriating when you look into the faces
of these kids who are being helped by
the schools and then you imagine that
someone could I'll say theoretically be
paid money to hurt their education and
take and say yes for the money I will
engage in a lawsuit my group will engage
in a lawsuit that will hurt these kids
because you know what we care more about
the money and then we do about their
futures the establishment and education
usually will tell you that we who run
the regular district Public Schools are
chagrined by this money draining to
these few charter schools it's costing
our education system we desperately need
this money to improve and it's draining
to these little satellite charters out
there
imagine if the model is completely
reversed where the bulk of the schools
are charters it's hard to imagine how
that drainie argument would be made when
quote-unquote the real schools are the
schools of choice new media the internet
social media is is the way to reach more
and more people it's also let's face it
a low cost way to reach people more and
more people are expecting their news on
their iPhones and Android devices and
iPads I've worked in more traditional
cable news outlets and and other kinds
of you know traditional journalism in
some ways this kind of work we're doing
now is more responsive to to people
both in an immediate sense of timeliness
when things happen and break and the
Twitter world blows up about a certain
issue as well as a kind of opinion on
the ground a kind of a grassroots a
style an opinion that otherwise would be
ignored by the gatekeepers who actually
feel like we're helping real children
you know potentially so it's not just a
job it's a cause